>>Cindy: And we have a
conversation about it,
and the conversation
should build on each other.
So you should build on--
>>Student: When you're filling out the
college application and you're putting
down each class you did and your grade.
And then you're like, oh wow, if I
would have done just like one more thing
in English, I could have gotten
a little bit higher of a grade.
And I think like, making students
realize that sooner would help them
and like, decrease the stress.
>>Cindy: An academic seminar block works
because we teach students how to learn.
We started addressing this
metacognitive, these social,
emotional skills, how
to build relationships,
how to ask questions in class.
We've been successful to the
point that a hundred percent
of our seniors this year have been
accepted into post-secondary programs.
>>Our students come from across New
Mexico with varying degrees of skill.
So we realized that we needed a place in
the day for them to learn how to learn.
We started down the path
with ninth grade academy,
where students could either
catch up or get ahead.
>>Eric: Good morning, class.
>>Students: Good morning, Mister Crites.
>>Eric: Just a reminder of the
schedule for the week, okay?
So today is project work time.
>>Ninth grade academy is a class that
meets every day for thirty-five minutes.
We start the year off getting kids
ready to be high school students,
things like teaching them
how to read their schedule,
and make sure that they know how to find
their classes, how to use school email,
how to use their planners, how
to organize their notebooks.
The purpose of it is really to
teach kids the non-cognitive skills
that they're going to
need to be successful.
>>Student: Use study hall
to the best of your ability.
>>Kara: Although we could kind of
spread that out more, to just using time
to the best of your ability.
>>Kara: Ninth grade academy, I find it
really helpful, because we learn a lot
of ways to work on our testing
skills and our studying skills
and it gives us a little bit of
extra time to get help from teachers,
and just working on life skills.
>>Eric: What are the skills and
knowledge that you have developed
that you want to teach
next year's ninth graders
through a presentation,
some kind of performance?
>>Student: Okay, so it will be like a
ninth grader's guide to surviving NMSA.
Okay.
>>Student: Our presentation is
called measure twice, cut once.
>>Student: Don't compare yourself
to your friends and peers,
that one's really important.
[cheering]
>>Molly: Ninth grade academy did help
teach me how to manage time and be able
to keep all my classes in order.
Skills like these will help me get
through these next three years.
>>Cindy: Senior seminar was created with
the purpose of getting every student
into the college, university or
conservatory of their choice,
by providing them with the
support they needed to get there.
>>Acacia: Some students may not
have the vocabulary and the skills
to start the college
application process.
It may just feel too foreign to them.
The objective of senior seminar is
to have some time set
aside that's dedicated
to the college application process.
And the time is structured in a way
that makes the application
process manageable.
>>Anything about admissions essays,
any way to improve that process?
>>Student: I think it was
pretty great this year.
>>Student: We had a lot of time
for editing and had a lot of time
to like, really go in depth.
>>Acacia: Some of the things we
do include the admissions essay.
We have an English teacher come in and
discuss what good writing looks like.
We look at asking for letters
of recommendation and how to ask
for a letter that's going to be strong.
I know that that got some
students motivated to jump in
and start working harder on their
college application process.
>>Do you feel like you have a pretty
good sense, leaving this school,
the difference between the financial
aid offers that you've received?
>>Julia: We talked a lot about
deciphering student loans
and what it means to take out loans,
and what are the implications?
It's just those sort of things that
really get you thinking like an adult.
>>Acacia: I mean, this is like
the goal that we're trying to--
>>John: The application process
is very long and difficult,
and so having that class time and a
teacher who knew what she was talking
about and could help you, really helped.
Because if I had to do that all by
myself, I wouldn't have gotten anywhere.
>>Acacia: Having that time
every day when I can check
in with them gives them the
motivation to eventually find a school
or a career that's satisfying
and interesting to them.
>>Cindy: We're showing a
closing of the achievement gap
for socioeconomically
disadvantaged and Hispanic students.
From the indicators that we do have,
we know what we're doing is working.
>>Teacher: Good to see you.